[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're going to love it here
greatest city in the world nor the next
chapter in its long history of greatness
[Music]
so wonderful to welcome the brand to the
Lakers family we're definitely going to
the tournament this year they've better
[Applause]
go back to Cleveland we don't want you
[Music]
nights of house Lakers tonight we
commence what is sure to be a glorious
season the beginning of the end of the
long drought for the king of the east
now Don's the purple and gold and
together we will restore the glory of
the greatest house in the Western realm
now please eat
especially you Ingram no burner you go
pestle bran first now oh sorry
you must have burned your tongue your
breath so I hear you're to be involved
in the production of CGM - is that
correct yes that's right Oh delightful
well I was thinking if you're looking to
say reprise Shawn Bradley's character
I'm a very accomplished actor actor
editions prohibitions an annoying sect
of extremist Kobe family this is done by
Lakers fan Lang sir not lik affirms the
Kobe fans they don't accept LeBron they
think he's a soft [ __ ] you can't play
defense I'm Brandon well that's what
they say alright let me talk to them
don't bother LeBron you can reason with
them just ignore him
if I could win back the families of
Cleveland I can certainly win the hearts
of a few crazy Kobe fan links good
people of Los Angeles give my chance
give him a chance like you I have much
respect for Kobe cuz he's the GU never
be Kobe brother I'm not trying to be
well you should yeah he's better than
you okay well is there anything I could
possibly do to win you over
gave us a billion go what else Kobe
tattooed on his head definitely no
hunter championship
yes okay you got winner six
championships salmon what you realize
cool be only one five yeah but he's a
closer [ __ ] finishes ice I finish
according to the analytics maesters I'm
actually more clutch than Kobe
nah Kobe's a killer like a mum bass well
I built a school Wow
oh you built a school yeah that's cuz
you're soft yeah you have nothing to
prove to these fools they're just a few
nuts living in their parents bonds
they'll come around believe real Kobe
fans will never accept the Frog he
doesn't have the Mamba mentality Toby
never missed a game winner I have
dedicated my life to the worship of
clovie and I would rather die than
worship the broad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm any update on the air jimmy
situations handled my leash he is in
good spirits and should be returning to
practice today
yeah so he no longer wants to be traded
well that must be him now do something
don't worry you can't do [ __ ] against me
I hope that means you've worked on your
defense
I'll take those to tear out cousins the
muffin make us boy and that their mangy
goat when a mob whatever's left of you
chili living cowards off the court
oh that's actually no dressing are using
[Music]
as we said of how schools if you're not
mortally wounded you can still play for
10 minutes too big part of me and you
see my heart not now Thomas it might be
time to beat this situation is untenable
what's terrible it's very terrible it's
one of the most tenable situations I've
ever attended oh hey remember last
season we were a three seed I swear this
will work out just fine
if we're just a seed
your rotations well I do suppose I like
Robert Covington's hustle how exciting
is this Lord Commander Jimmy can take us
over the top he could change everything
with its intensity oh here it comes now
they're mini carriage door does have a
lot of baggage I'd like to be traded
please
[Music]
shall we complete this process now
sometimes I like to pretend that I'm
King James blessed by the gods to choose
my army my Lord Commander and my home
but alas I am NOT I am sir marShon
Brooks the journeyman cell sword who not
long ago was fighting in the distant
lands of China's spending years
reassembling what remained of my
shattered spirit only to land a seat on
the dreary benches of Memphis but fate
is a curious thing for yesterday
how sons requested my services and
offered real assets in return so trevor
ariza and picks seems i shall finally
prove to everyone that i am a knight
worthy of minutes and what i once feared
was my twilight was in fact my dorm
welcome to house sons
thank you sir marShon Brooks at your
service wait marShon Brooks yes actually
traded for Darren Brooks you were oh
damn it they sent the wrong Brooke House
quiz they sent the wrong Brooks are you
bloody serious oh how the fickle tides
of fate proceed as quickly as they crash
upon my shorts and though my sandcastles
may were there and wash the deft hands
of hope must always be there
[Music]
dears Jennifer I've received your Raven
and I beseech you understand
I am trying I try every day to bring you
the ring you so desire the Boogie Knight
himself they say our bigs can't defend
please I've got a torn Achilles okay
last I saw this lot you all were getting
swept away faster than a Horace Mann
case at house Mavericks
oh please boogie regale us with the
tales of your extensive tournament
experience better none than yours don't
let him get in your head oh good on you
all for giving Jimmer another shot what
no I'm wait I'm not going to fall for
your hurtful tricks anymore you see it
seems the tables have turned
unlike you I have to put Achilles and
friends have you like my socks now [ __ ]
what a fellowship y'all have almost
makes up for the lack of rings the lord
of light-hearted locker room chemistry
smiles upon our brotherhood who smiles
upon you boogie he's gone her rings and
no friends - which of those can you
offer me friends I prefer rings within
join us together we shall make it past
the second round whoa whoa I don't want
this guy here he's like mess with our
flow you know I mean we have like good
vibes and also like we have same agent
and he says it might affect my minutes
doesn't matter it's water under the bay
bridge I'm signing with house warriors
what No
he's full of it everybody knows House
Warriors over the gold cap they can't
afford you know it's probably mid-level
exception it's it's an exception I of
course know what that is and fully
understand it my mind is buzzing 4-iron
a heart
tankinson pokey cousins turned into was
snake hey roids to the Oakland's Willis
rings all around give his head bando
rebrand as a ring chasers crowd for bar
Fridays boogie damn the only thing more
hopeless than this Brotherhood is your
board career you know I expect it to be
a bastard but a coward - I'd rather die
the chair the court with curry no no I'm
sorry I mean the good I mean Stef and
the rest of those servants we've got no
chance we had no chance but we do now
the lord of light hearted chemistry is
very powerful to the humble he giveth
but to the greedy he taketh away
the Warriors defeat can only come from
within no house compare the likes of
dream on KD and gossips their golden cup
runneth over with us let him go
hope you enjoy the regular season you're
[ __ ] losers I hope y'all get off get a
seat so I can see your faces when we
sweep you again I'll crush you like I
crushed my Lord Commander to see know
the way out of here he'll get himself
rejected eventually my mind gives up
buzzing fired a heart attack seems very
cool
cuz it's turned into a snake he writes
to do plants when it rings all around
did he say mando rebrand as a reach aces
drown
none hot Oh raining has brought us some
news daddy's good house blazes and quiet
the night Rodney owned by the sea
brethren rejoice and give care exemple
Nick's house is your now apparently my
boy hey good luck at Cleveland Nick
see look here damar dreamers on LeBron
again it's like a triple switch or
something exactly what are you reading
we're studying house warriors defensive
tactics against King James it wasn't
their tactics it was their talent we
have the talent
we just need smart strategy and for the
guards to finally smile on us maybe they
are tomorrow this is our chance King
James has gone from our path but he has
also gone from our excuses if we fail to
conquer these this year it could be the
end for all of us my lord you've always
believed in us we will reward your faith
I swear it I'm afraid faith is not
enough here we pay a northern price for
a blessing
the guards demand a sacrifice lord Ujiri
I pledge that I will do whatever it
takes
yes we'd give anything for the six I
know forgive me
God wake up God God Norman what are you
doing right we're making a trade a trade
why didn't anyone tell me well you know
you did trade for a horse once and I
think the older Giri doesn't he's so
annoying
excuse me no no no I'll do it
I won't this must be some sort of
mistake he was here for a long time not
a good time
what where's Lord you Jerry it'll all be
over soon
no I demand to see lawyer Jerry where is
no you Jerry
my lord you can't you said you wouldn't
God's plan Drake have you all gone mad
we don't make a trade there will be no
banners here oh is that what they said
it house Tonto when they traded away
jame party oh that's not the same silver
Lord bless this train for despair and
for the good of the realm how could you
do this to your most loyal Knights not
just him also
Jake Yakko hold on hold little point we
hold him
[Music]
all right some in the trade raptor
No
by Jacob Paul Jakob burrows please I'll
do whatever you ask for shoot more fries
Luigi Giri how could you do this she's
my best friends okay I'll be your new
best friend Josh Norman Kyle
is there any other way which ride they
didn't want you please please
Oh trial defense of shooting
[Music]
hide the ball wait wait I almost forgot
we also owe them a first run Pig okay
we're good we should be good trade
wrapped up take these nights to the new
house
hey MA panda pick and Jake puddle my
friend well whoever will get it back it
better be a bloody monster
[Music]
so the key here again is spacing I need
you in the corner and if your man so
much as looks my way then I'm gonna get
it to you then I go for three yes but is
merely a pump fake no I pull the ball
down I step over the line and I whack
down the big four contested fade away to
from the elbow no that's exactly what
you shouldn't do Chris you know I can
hit that shot over anybody although it's
not about hitting shots it's about
hitting efficient shots not you two with
this efficiency fad whatever happened to
the days when Knights would go
one-on-one mano a mano in the paint in a
slow grinding duel know if you want a
role here on house Rockets you must
understand the system study the
analytics they study plenty Camero
please I remember when you used to be
fun
whatever happened to Banana Boat Chris
he learned how to win and he wants to
teach his friends so they could win
together I want to win it's just it's
all so boring these days analytics
efficiency defense hmm you know what
come with me I want to show you
something
whoa
[Music]
half Camaro welcome to the Johnson
spacing Center here are misters test the
frontiers of knowledge to give house
Rockets a competitive edge what's that
why that's our namesake the rocket we
value long-range weaponry here house
rockets has never shied away from
experimentation some produce incredible
results and others not so much
what is this for that was the AL Ming's
chamber pad Oh mellow have a look at
this
what is that those are moons orbiting
another world makes you think you might
not be the center of the universe after
all huh so you're saying I'm just
another planet no he's saying you are a
moons James Harden is the planet
well actually Chris I am a star and
stars should be starters mellow just
needs a headband I'm gonna put a hoodie
here mellow you're not getting no I bet
the only reason I'm not starting is
because D'Antoni's still bitter about
New York and now now now he's just
working off the model the model it's not
possible I can't just suit 33s again
look right here James
if the model is correct you could triple
your offense and pull us out of this
slump but what if I miss them I could go
over 27 myself ah
but James what if you make them
[Music]
how what Camello what are you doing here
Carmelo's interested in the model really
analytics Melo this is the model we feed
her data and she gives us answers
untainted by human bias huh
why to shift six arms and full booth she
was designed by a bunch of nerds who
let's just say have it had too much
experience with the anatomy of a female
Carmelo you have to understand this
machine it doesn't care about your
feelings the model only knows pure
analytics if this thing truly knows
basketball then I should have nothing to
fear show me how it works these are your
career stats let's speed them in hope
she likes empty calories
[Music]
okay model should circle mellow be in
the Hall of Fame ah look at that first
ballot yeah brilliant now I want to know
what my role here should be mayor oh
sure take it away
model what should be my role on house
rockets you should have done that the
other Lane this model is nothing but a
hater Harris this bloody thing even work
don't comment oh that's where the
computers are computers what's a
computer I don't know the computers do
all the calculations needed to run the
model oh do they will do any of you even
watch basketball
have a good forum what what is the ice
these poor souls witnessed the dark ages
of basketball in the early aughts
the endless post plays the long twos sir
Jordan on the Wizards after a second
Finals appearance by house Nets they
couldn't bear it any longer the gouge
out their eyes but on a positive note it
turns out they're perfect for doing
double blinded analytics many became
computers the rest became referees I
don't like your shooting all right well
we really should get going though you're
beginning to taint their judgment this
is madness well if you'd settle your
emotional response you'd see it's all
quite logical really no no this is all
wrong
your cold heartless numbers know nothing
of my value anyone with eyes can see the
beauty of my game a ten-time all-star
behind PJ Tucker really marquise Chris
well I refuse to accept it and I'll
never accept it why did you even bring
me here because you're worth the risk
another veteran minimum Carmello Lord
Morey has given you a chance and it may
be the only one you have left well
that's ridiculous I just need the ball
I can still take any night one-on-one
just give me the rocket off huh Oh what
come on II mean New York
[Music]
interesting of seven hells Austin Rivers
[Music]
I can't wait to share the court with you
and a legendary sir Dirk
would you like to see him you see like
he says spirit is strong but I am afraid
there is not much time left
okay he's down to ten minutes a battle
my but come you will make him very happy
sir Dirk remember you can fight for this
house for as long as you like don't go
but I don't have much time left
maybe only six seasons of eggs that's
fine that's totally fine is now a good
time
sir kristaps is here - yes yes Dirk
someone special wants to see you hello
my euro father you shaved your beard
Tyson oh that's a kristaps Cristal stops
you're on LC Mavericks I am yeah
Lord mark this is truly a wonderful gift
almost makes up for the time I took a
giant pay cut okay to stay with house
Mouse we don't you use the gold on
Chandler Parsons alright okay not good
okay well I will let you boys load to
talk about whatever European things you
guys want to talk about like wine and
bread cheese I get it alright later
dudes mark is actually it's very cool
guy your grace
I want to learn everything off to teach
me let me bask in the light of your
wisdom I will tell you what is the most
important yes please loyalty for 56
years
I have form only House Mavericks colors
even as those colors went through a
questionable rebrand and though I showed
my opponents no mercy
I made no enemies because I betrayed no
house
me why did you abandon your house your
families well I was on house NICs say no
more okay yikes yikes never mind
Chris stops to use and swear your
loyalty to house more freaks yes I do
thousand in the name of Dirk Nowitzki of
house Mavericks I hereby declare you sir
next Dirk I got wait hold on with all
due respect he said I was the next Dirk
like like I'm gonna go oh that's right
okay Chris stops you will be the next
Dirk until Luka comes of age right but
I'm already the go through night right
I'm scoring roughly 20 points a battle
but if maybe both of you are the next
duck we do double ducks yeah it could be
double ducks
it'll be triple Dirk screw the truth
with those three boulders who is the
artist I think I also pulled max ich
liebe satis the next me sir our next
battle starts in 8 hours we need to
start your stretches oh don't thank you
JJ I'll be right there
all right boys time to play some
basketball
[Music]
what the hell coos oh come on probably
would have been more off-target if I let
you alone well the arrow cost 200 gold
your face 200 gold foot right hey
weren't you cutting ties at them yeah
but I go get that arrow back it's gonna
be a collector's item
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alonzo we're not sure it's safe to climb
in co2 boots it's not one disease you
look around knew all your minutes bricks
I earned toss your knobs Oh think of the
space would you let me play power
forward yes anything even though I'm
clearly a center so whatever you want
because together we will bring back show
time
too bad Lord James would never trade me
here he just hates house Lakers he's
always been jealous of big markets never
rich handles Dell but you'd have to give
up your entire young call for my rights
I would trade every single one of them
for just a chance to play with you
between you and me they're a bunch of
fools and overhyped
Squires even the ball boy for long
though good riddance demanders Oh from a
father and once he's gone we'll bring in
a real Lord Commander like Jason wait
stop just son of us are you completely
mad don't train me I'm really good
except for shooting free throws and
three-pointers layups but uh oh just the
numbers you pick he was the number two
pick the things I do for rings oh come
on guys shake it off you're fine just a
little lay off push from the greatest
day in the realm someone going to help
us up well I suppose there's always next
year
oh yeah
you
[Music]
welcome to the Sept of Baelor a shrine
to bad front office decisions the kind
that have led all of you here to the
draft lottery today we gather in the
presence of the lottery guards to
witness the bestowing of the first peek
I am Marc Tatum hand of the High
Commissioner wears a silver lord yes
actually
and besides this is sort of my thing
yeah you know what let's just take a
moment to appreciate Marc Tatum it's
right let's give it a love to the guy
behind the guy okay
all right thanks as per tradition each
house has chosen one delegate to
represent them I do question some of
your delegate choices but then again
questionable decisions are why many of
you find yourselves here house pelicans
come on you know who the foundlings want
to see that's better um excuse me house
Mavs what is this well uh triple Dirk's
okay well you got to pick one
representative so figure out who is the
next Dirk in the next ten seconds please
all right well I mean I'm the most
experienced well I'm clearly the face of
House Mavericks and I'm from darks
hometown so yeah I mean it's hard we all
have really good cases right you know
what how'd you guys sort this out next
season House Lakers okay so we are all
good everyone knows how this works
not really right well each house will
have a chance to make their final pleas
with lottery guards as to why they
should get the first pick so who would
like to be the first to make a claim
great the goat was made poop on the
floor excuse me no not you sarva why is
a goat here because it's a metaphor and
it's funny okay well please send a new
representative down preferably a human
okay the floor is open
Oh take a stop here
I would say to the gods that you should
give house Kings the first pick
because actually now it would go to the
sixes oh crap yeah okay gods
you should give house Kings the second
pick yeah then it would go to you house
Celtx I believe wait what who made I
made this okay do someone else know else
has fallen harder than that of the
grizzly circus all is gone but Chandler
Parsons and his stupid contract remain
could be worse bless us Oh lottery
guards with the squire Zion
so that grit and grind may rise again as
a bane to all Western powers great house
NYX has not had a first pick in over 30
years
Lord 50 we finally have cast off or
overrated European big man to make room
for the great side please gods take that
for data and give us mix the first bit
oh yeah please Faust NYX gets die and
they'll just send them away in another
terrible trade the right you sir Chris
tops are now banned from the garden okay
you can't just ban an opposing Knight
from your ena does anyone else want to
make a plea to the gods ah
so Devon welcome screw how sons they
rejected our alliance and stole the
first pic from us last year yeah they
already have Luka honey don't wait so
who did you guys take I think true young
uh what no we talked you Andre Aten oh
he'll sleep in this year it's actually
pretty solid yeah
yeah it's quietly had a decent square
Sir Anthony Davis you want to make a
plea poor house pelicans yes read this
and we will trade you two house Lakers
right okay let's try this again
we house pelicans are but a humble house
and we kindly ask you for your blessing
Zion is the hero that house pelicans
needs a knight you could take us further
than one playoff series win in seven
seasons we once had a transformative
around night but he lacked the
altitude to take the fortitude it takes
to commit to a small mark okay it's my
fault that I sorry I couldn't beat house
warriors with Drew holiday and half a
season of boogie cousins um thank you ad
house Cavs would you like to make your
case if the gods truly care to see the
squire's iron flourish they should give
the first pick to house Cavs well he
will be surrounded by championship
caliber veterans and the Lord who knows
how to win oh please you know there's a
reason I left twice oh yeah because
you've made house Blake is such a
welcoming place for young talent I'm
just fitting out now hey Kevin yes
LeBron I miss you I I miss you too
all right guys let's maybe keep the
overt tampering to a minimum okay then
who's next house Hawks wait every house
he has to go oh yes
house Hawks please go ahead empty
lottery God's our house is on the rise
Zion joins our maybe a 42 year old Vince
Carter won't have to play 17 minutes of
battle okay who else in SOTA I mean how
many number one picks do you guys need
to make the tournament apparently more
than three this is fun hey do us know
who else house Wizards I mean who
wouldn't want to play with Dwight Howard
by the way when does John wall's
Supermax start next year asking for
friend okay who else we got how schools
oh yeah I'm sure lion wants to spend his
first year having Nate show a little
respect for many of these houses this is
the highlight of their season yeah oh
yeah why is that maybe instead of
looking to the gods you all should be
looking at yourselves
rubbish houses with uninspiring Lord
commanders foolish masters of trade
arrogant Lords no bad
these are things at night no matter how
great can't overcome I learned that the
hard way Xion maybe the prince who was
promised but he will not save you
because if you don't give a goat the
support he needs then he's gonna walk
out the door and all you're gonna be
left with poop on the floor all right
well on that note why don't we go ahead
and see what the first pick and the
winner of the zion lottery is House
Pelican
[Music]
your grace you want to do see me yes
I like to pretend there is legs
you see lower houses there the hens and
I and the Fox that snatches their little
babies and you collected so many so much
talent
almost too much fostonia there's no such
thing is too much and the one thing Lord
pop would have never lost control of
this house Spurs of the East lucky for
you there's one last road trip before
the tournament starts I suggest you find
a way to get on nights on the same page
or else you would never this city loves
me like they love the king in the fourth
get it done
[Music]
unbelievable gotta share a temp with the
rotation guys we muster heroes last year
you're feeling cramped expand your mind
Squyres these days so entitled better
stop calling ask wise Marcus you don't
scare me Terry you think you're some
wise veteran why is that I've seen that
before that there is a soul box when you
saw him with House Spurs your soul in
personality go into the box so it's like
a Spurs culture thing I didn't want it
to come to this but there's too much
talent here in this room for us to be
treading water in the force see the soul
box will help us contain our emotions
and our egos so that this group can
reach its potential also makes you tell
us dirt that thing's the reason nobody
heard of me in San Antonio yeah that's
the reason hole do it all right out I
want you to close your eyes and place
your hand on the box sir Al Horford do
you hereby commit fully sacrifice your
soul for a good of house Celtx
[Music]
so did it work or why they didn't flinch
all right who's next
anyone I'll do it okay no lucky give me
that box I'll do it Thanks this is for
Knights Marcus the smart I I can I'm
sorry my whole game is about emotion
jaelyn
oh I'm just worried about my brand is
all what about you Kyrie subjugate the
light of my soul to your rectangular
prism no way can't even commit to the
next year Wow what a leader okay then
why don't you do it well I just don't
want to jeopardize my mama mentality is
off yeah god forbid you stop shooting
20-footers oh please you're one to talk
you know what clearly this was a bad
idea okay
you guys are obviously not the Spurs and
I am clearly not Lord pop no you know
you're Brad Stevens best X's and O's man
I've ever known
yeah nobody can write out of time out
plays like you yeah well unfortunately
there's no time out long enough for me
to fix all of this team's issues who
over there was who said that
the time no wait Time Lord I thought
that was just a nickname do all things
people don't know about me
don't get enough minutes tell me about
it but I'm pretty versatile can rebound
like a block like a stop time where'd
you learn how to do that Texas A&M but
you were only there for two years
well was I so how does one just stopped
I'm just asking questions here it's a
magic potion I'm called sudah it's
banned in the realm since Jason Kidd
used it against House Lakers late in a
battle when your no timeouts left
exactly how long are we talking about
here that will last leader you've come
up with the way to solve our problems 34
years Trevor comes first
why 34 the truth 34 is the truth number
guy who's worse than Dwyane Wade
actually no that's just how much soda I
have all right you've got this little
commander yeah you're Brad Stevens well
you can do this little commander are you
all mad do you really think he could
just come up with something magical out
of timeout play that gonna fix all of
our chemistry is juice yeah you know
what I do because I'm Brad and Steven
broke Time Lord Benny when you are right
[Music]
whoa commander you look like you've aged
34 years yep so you you didn't nope so
what's all that mostly just gibberish
gave up 20 years ago actually what's
that all right I've got some good news
and some bad news bad news first lucky
got frozen in time with me
the soda spilled on him unfortunately
for lucky he swore a blood oath to
always perform during timeouts obviously
never thinking he will yeah but he kept
performing he was juggling dancing doing
those wacky dunks man was he funny by
year two he was mostly performance stuff
that could be done from a chair like
balancing bowls singing whatever it was
around year three where he stopped
talking he was just my men and
deliriously flailing his arms by year
four I thought he was doing this long
bit where he would just play dead by
year five I realized it wasn't a bit so
what's the good news
well I came up with a few pretty clever
inbound clays it might get us to the
second round
[Music]
[Music]
and together we'll rule the world from
edge to edge Thank You Kyrie I'll be in
touch what's he doing here oh he was
just asking questions what are you doing
here thought it was quite generous we
let you hang around for six battles now
you're just being greedy with my time
clearly my defense has yet to earn your
respect I respect your effort and I
heard you said nice things about me
after the battle you're worthy opponent
if he liked me as your opponent's he had
loved me as your teammate free-agent
talk we'll wait until after the
tournament oh come on have a little fun
gods no you're not having any year if
you want some scrub go to an eliminated
house if you want to King earn him pure
gold it's funny I thought your throne be
made of salt you're insolent I've
dropped 40 on men for less
they were lesser men oh please didn't I
just dropped fifty on you we are done
here well then I guess good luck in New
York who says I'm going to New York Oh
everybody the garden is the biggest
stage in the realm I would be the goat
if I turn that house around and if you
fail on this biggest stage in the realm
listen to your burner you can't win with
those cats what you need is a dog a
hungry lawyer hound you're proud to be a
dog that's a new one men love dogs
but they loathe our snakes you're trying
to lure me to house Clippers you're
doing an awful job you know now that I
think about it house Clippers would be a
terrible fit I mean we all know you only
take the hardest Road and house Clippers
would be smooth sailing really got Lord
West builder of Empires
two Mac slots the best Lord Commander in
the realm and a bunch of hungry loyal
dogs just looking for their alpha it's
almost too easy
and besides you came to Los Angeles it
would be so unfair to King James
upstaged night after night in his own
city by the man who was always second
best no for free agents you're very
loyal to House Clippers loyalty is what
dogs do best oh yeah
Kady my turn to sit on the throne I
should be going
you've been very generous with your time
we should talk
maybe if you didn't miss all those who
could have expected men we gather today
to celebrate for if the whispers are
true sir Yanis will be anointed the most
valuable night thank you but how can I
be deemed the most valuable when I
couldn't even get us to their finals
King James used to crush house Raptors
without breaking a sweat
they were a different house then they
didn't have that monster we should be
proud we won 60 battles this year yes
but it is all for nothing our tournament
is over the offseason has come and if
the maesters are right Taranto be
heading east which means it's going to
be hard for us to even make confidence
finals again which is right on we should
test the market maybe sign with house
pelicans again or house fools
I hear house Lakers needs Talent as a
former knight of house Suns
I know misery and this is not it sure
we're defeated but we are not without
hope for we have the honor of fighting
alongside true greatness not just of
skill but of character the king of the
north may rule the east for now but I
recognize only one true king and his
name is long and full of lettuce yarnís
atella kupo is my king from this day
until his last day do you know what I do
want to be here
last year I fought side-by-side with
King James I didn't think we'd find
another goat in the East not in my
career and I was wrong
Yanis is not only the most valuable
knight in the realm
he is the king in the East I remember
the days when Brandon Knight was our
best Knight or maybe it was Ramon
Sessions
as Yanis has grown so as the dignity and
respect of this house we have not known
hope like this since the days sir
Alcindor and the Big O and it's all
thanks to Yanis the king of the year
[Music]
oh how quickly they forget
nine years I would East from three one
down I slayed the Warriors from the
brink of baldness I have restored my
hairline and from the ashes of a lost
season
I will return rested reborn regrind to
reclaim my throne as the true king of
[Music]
yeah all right cut cut JaVale you jumped
on the wrong basket Bello what are you
doing in front if we want you the banana
because I'm a star on the broad and star
Shmi in leading role alright well hold
on Matt particles stop strangling Derek
with the physical wire
oh it says here in the script that I
swear 95 miles to kick his ass I figured
I figured I'd do it
[Music]
someone get those guys out of here also
where did magic girl he was supposed to
be here excuse me can i play Kevin of
Durant in the mobs
no Brandon just your yolk in the wave we
need to do anyway I stand by it that I
take Mike muscala over Brook Lopez a
hundred times out about you know Larry
I'm really glad I quit house Lakers now
I can just watch battles and send Ravens
hang out with you my best rival friend
and none of its tampering I just wish
there was a way to know what a new game
of zones came out come on Larry use your
person voice what I was saying you know
trash talk Larry Bird we're past that if
you just hit the subscribe button they
will notify you when a new game of zones
comes out